[Musique]
nous sommes aux archives départementales
des yvelines en compagnie de mathilde
oeuvre jour un jour vous êtes en charge
du développement des publics
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer un peu comment fonctionne ce
nouveau jeu numérique qui s'appelle le
legging les lui porte
oui alors l'énigme des victoires c'est
une énigme en ligne une enquête
entièrement sur internet qui est ouverte
à tous et qui a démarré le 17 mars
dernier qui se terminera le 17 avril
est-ce que vous pouvez nous montrer
comme parisienne avec plaisir allez
allez vaste artistes déjà comment on
fait pour pour accéder à ce jeu oui
alors il faut se connecter sur le site
internet des archives départementale des
yvelines et sur la page d'accueil vous
avez une information alors un appareil
un vous cliquez sur cette information et
vous arrivez sur la page dédiée vous
arrive et on vous explique le scénario
en fait on va partir dans une enquête
avec une journaliste d'investigation qui
s'appelle léa pinatar et 7 léa pinatar a
reçu une lettre d'un certain victor
victor georget et soul eater georges et
lui fait part d'un document
extraordinaire qui parle d'eux
vie porte temporel qui se trouvent sur
le territoire des yvelines
il aurait déjà retrouvé la trace de
quatre de ses portes temporel vous serez
donc dans la peau de l'oea et c'est à
vous de prendre la suite de l' enquête
une fois qu'on a pris connaissance du
scénario on peut commencer le jeu bon
joueur se retrouve dans la situation de
quelqu'un en salle de lecture
il a commandé de nombreux cartons
d'archivés
il va falloir qu'ils commencent à ouvrir
des boîtes et à regarder ce qui vient à
l'intérieur de ces boîtes alors
évidemment il ya un ordre déjà il faut
trouver les bonnes boîtes c'est un jeu
très réaliste comme si on se retrouvait
réellement salle de lecture avec des
documents un conseil prendre des notes
dès le départ c'est un jeu qui est fait
aussi pour découvrir une initiation à la
recherche historique
c'est vraiment pour ça qu'on l'a créée
donc l'idée c'est de découvrir de se
plonger vraiment dans des documents qui
sont de réels document histoire
d'apprendre ce que c'est que la
recherche est évidemment quand on fait
mes recherches et bien et bien c'est ça
on apprend à apprendre le temps une fois
que vous avez fini toutes ces énigmes
vous envoyer un formulaire pour valider
votre participation au concours via des
lots à gagner
tout à fait en fait il ya deux
catégories dans ce concours il ya une
catégorie grand public et une catégorie
collégiens des yvelines qui récompense
chacun 30 joueurs dans chaque catégorie
et parfois on voit des très beaux lots
des ordinateurs des tablettes
voilà des lots un peu technologique donc
ça mais bon les collégiens mais aussi
les pour le groupe et le grand public
tout à fait en tout ce sont 60 gagnants
soyez tout de même passion il faut
compter trois heures pour faire
l'intégralité du parcours c'est bon j'ai
fini les lignes j'ai envoyé le
formulaire et puis maintenant c'est à
vous de jouer